محاولات واضحه لسلطات طيران لتشتيت
الانتباه عن الاحتجاجات الداخليه في
البلاد وتوجيه الانبار اثاره بقصف كردستان
العراق وتاره اخرى بمحاولات ارسال لاسلحه
اليمن والتصعيدي هناك وتاره ثالثا بملف
المفاوضات النوويه الذي يموت سريريا لكن
مياه الخليج حاضره ايضا ما تؤججها طهران
بمسيراتها الفاعله في حرب اوكرانيا وهي
جزء من هذا التحديث ولهذا هناك استراتيجيه
اخرى تعمل عليها واشنطن لكنها لم تفصح عن
كامله تفاصيلها برنامجنا التجريبيا في
الشرق الاوسط للتغلب على المسايرات ولكن
لماذا المسيرات تحديدا لانها تحديد
التكنولوجيا الاكبر للامن الاقليمي في راي
الجنرال الامريكي كاريلا حديثنا ان يتماشى
مع اعلانا سابقا لوزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بني جانس نريد احباط على الهجمات
الايرانيه صواريخ الكروز او بالمسيرات
والوسيله السعي لتاسيس تحالفا دفاعيا جوي
بقياده واشنطن تل ابيب وطهران في حرب ظل
المامون بسنوات